bonjour à tous donc on va débuter par
l'agenda de la semaine
alors vendredi nicolas sarkozy était en
allemagne à berlin pour la conférence
des entreprises familiales
il est intervenu après la chancelière
angela merkel
ce matin le président à petit déjeuner
au medef avec eric woerth où il a
rencontré plusieurs chefs d'entreprises
et cette rencontre s'est très bien passé
alors demain mardi 16 juin
nicolas sarkozy se rendra au groupe
l'est républicain au sénat puis
déjeunera avec gérard larcher et bruno
retailleau à 18h30 donc nos débats
hebdomadaire les débats de l'alternance
qui sera animée par yves foulon député
maire d'arcachon autour du thème comment
rendre la france plus compétitive donc
c'est toujours avec cette volonté de
vouloir ouvrir le siège à nos militants
et d'avoir un contact très direct avec
les membres de la direction à des
républicains
alors mercredi 17 juin un déjeuner à
l'initiative de nicolas sarkozy et de
jean luc moudenc donc maire de toulouse
avec les maires républicains des
communes de plus de 100000 habitants
ensuite aura lieu la commission
exécutive de des républicains aux sièges
et enfin les rendez-vous de l'économie à
18h45 qui sont animés par eric woerth
donc jeudi 18 juin vous avez nicolas
sarkozy sera en déplacement en haute
savoie
puis interviendra à la fête de l'union
pour la vallée de l'oise et la ville
nouvelle donc à l'isle-adam chez le
député poniatowski à lundi 22 et mardi
23 juin
nicolas sarkozy sera en déplacement au
maroc où il rencontrera différentes
autorités
des parlementaires mais également le roi
du maroc
il y aura aussi
une rencontre avec les militants de la
fédération de casablanca des
républicains donc nous avons aussi de
nombreux militants républicains au maroc
le 29 juin
nicolas sarkozy sera en espagne
il y aura l'installation du groupe de
travail qui a été annoncé lors du
congrès du ppe avec mario rajoy et
différents groupes de travail notamment
sur la réforme de l'europe et
l'immigration seront mis en place avec
des députés européens des députés aussi
des parlementaires français et espagnol
voilà pour le point pour un jean da
alors de très bonnes nouvelles puisque
on va passer maintenant résultats des
différentes partiel et les résultats que
nous avons eu hier donc on a une
progression à très claire des
républicains avec un fn qui est
systématiquement en recul qui s'effondre
notamment peut l'observer dans les
hauts-de-seine où le front national fait
moins de 5% la gauche un socle de voix
qui s'effondrent également on peut le
voir à clichy donc on peut considérer
que c'est une chance historique après le
raz-de-marée que nous avons connu lors
des départementales en mars 2014
nous avons une chance historique dans
les hauts-de-seine de ne plus avoir une
seule ville qui soit dirigée par les
socialistes
il ya seulement trois villes dirigées
encore par les communistes mais le a
priori l'ensemble des villes du des
hauts-de-seine devrait être de droite et
c'est une très bonne nouvelle
donc on peut saluer la stratégie de
nicolas sarkozy la stratégie de
rassemblement qu'il a mis en place le
travail paie l'union nous permet de
gagner les différentes élections
l'opposition est en marche et nous
allons à poursuivre ce travail pour que
l'alternance en 2017 et lieu
vais rappeler quelques résultats vous
avez un héros ballottage favorable 47 42
à clichy raimu museau fait 48 83 à
puteaux ceccaldi-raynaud passe dès le
premier tour avec 62 77 % et et à
thionville donc une belle progression de
madame gros mèche avec 46 77 % et un fn
qui est en recul voilà donc c'était le
point sur sur les partiels
on voit bien que donc nous avons là la
bonne stratégie et lorsque les
républicains sont rassemblés nous ce que
nous sommes sur le terrain et que nous
avons des messages forts nous faisons
reculer la gauche et nous faisons
surtout reculer le front national je
vais céder la parole à à sébastian forum
pour évoquer le tour de france la
nouvelle campagne de françois hollande
bonjour à tous donc nous avons constaté
cette semaine qu après avoir étouffé
toute velléité de contestation de sa
candidature à la présidentielle de 2017
au congrès de poitiers que françois
hollande s'était lancé à corps perdu
dans une tournée électorale
donc on s'aperçoit que après ils ont une
véritable bulle crise à sion à l'elysée
de françois hollande ayant peur qu'à
chaque sortie une essuyé les huées et
les sifflets il a décidé de sortir de
l'elysée pour et bien commencé à peu
près deux ans avant l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 et bien une
tournée électorale mais il s'y est fort
mal pris puisqu'il a commencé par se
décommander aux 70 ans de l'unaf
c'est montrer le peu de cas qu'il fait
du fait des familles mais il avait
tellement peur de se faire siffler après
les attaques en règle qui l'a mis en
place via le gouvernement contre les
familles et bien il avait une véritable
crainte d'y aller donc il s'est
décommandé ce qui n'a pas empêché
d'ailleurs les congressistes de le
siffler copieusement quand madame
rossignol a voulu transmettre un message
de françois hollande
mais voilà il l'étalé donc il a préféré
aller aux 24 heures du mans et à vinexpo
sauf que finalement les sifflets qu'il
avait réussi à éviter à l'unaf et bien
ils ont redoublé à l'occasion de ses 24
heures du mans certains ont pu dire que
il a subi un accueil mitigé c'était plus
que mitigé pour ce qu'ils étaient et ont
pu entendre eux les nombreux s'il fut
sifflée et j'allais dire la vindicte qui
a eu lieu sur place et à cette occasion
aux 24 heures du mans
françois hollande à 2 ce a donné une
vraie leçon de république exemplaire à
manuel valls
lorsque s'adressant aux journalistes il
a dit qu'il n'était pas là pour son bon
plaisir et je pense que cette phrase qui
faisait référence au déplacement de
berlin de manuel valls eux mériteraient
la phrase de la part dont le prix de
l'humour politique qui est décerné
chaque année lorsque on voit le
comportement de monsieur hollande et
ensuite il est allé à vinexpo
et là on a retrouvé du grand françois
hollande c'est à dire l'homme qu'on
avait connue pendant 11 ans premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste qui était
l'homme de la synthèse et cet homme de
la synthèse on l'a retrouvé lorsqu'il
s'est exprimé sur sa position sa
position même si est ce que c'est
vraiment une position
la position sur l'amendement sénatorial
à la loi evin dans le cadre de la loi
macron parce que si quelqu'un a compris
quoi que ce soit et bien qu'il le dise
puisqu'il a dit à la fois qu'il fallait
respecter la loi evin toute la loi evin
rien que la loi evin mais que par
ailleurs il fasse il fallait savoir
faire preuve d'ouverture de
clarification et donc nous n'avons
toujours pas compris s'il était
favorable à l'amendement qui clarifie la
situation par rapport à la loi evin qui
a été voté par les sénateurs et qui a
été confirmé par la commission spéciale
de l'assemblée nationale ou s'il fallait
rester purement et simplement à la
version antérieure celle de la loi evin
comprenne qui pourra en voulant faire la
synthèse et bien finalement on reste
dans le flou et comme disait martine
aubry quand il ya du flou c'est qu'il ya
un loup et on peut toujours se poser la
question d'ailleurs si françois hollande
lui même ne serait pas sanctionnables du
fait de la loi evin telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui parce que je rappelle
l'interprétation de la cour de cassation
sur ce qui relève de la publicité pour
les boissons alcoolisées c'est un arrêt
du 3 novembre 2004 tout acte en faveur
d'un organisme d'un service d'une
activité d'un produit ou d'un article
ayant pour effet quel qu en soit la
finalité de rappeler une boisson
alcoolique et donc en se rendant à
vinexpo en prenant la parole à vinexpo
eh bien monsieur hollande a rappelé des
boissons alcooliques notamment une
boisson alcoolique qui est le vin donc
s'il avait il y avait besoin d'une
preuve qu'il était nécessaire qu'il est
nécessaire de clarifier cette loi evin
tel que l'a fait le sénat est tel que
l'a fait la commission spéciale en
étudiant la loi macron et bien c'est
vraiment celle là c'est que monsieur
hollande avec la définition de la cour
de cassation est sous le coup d'une
condamnation au titre de la loi evin